so one of the things that I that I
really really try to achieve with
software happy and what my entire 1
billion happy mission is is as a as an
as a thought that we are here for a
reason
right we're we're we're traveling the
physical world in this physical form to
make a difference right each of us in
his own or her own very different way so
some of us might make a difference by
developing a piece of code others might
make a difference by raising a wonderful
child or sharing a piece of knowledge or
even just smiling in someone's face and
changing the world that way right yet
that conviction that to have an impact
on life you have to pay unhappiness as
the text to get there is wrong right so
this this work is an attempt not to say
let's find happiness they eat Pray Love
way like you know you don't have to go
to an ashram and live life to achieve
that happiness but rather you know find
happiness on the path to impact right
and surprisingly the best path to impact
is actually to be happy there is so much
research that will tell you that happy
people are a lot more productive than
unhappy people
12% 1% specifically is the statistic but
but it's also you know it's also not
that's that's measuring their own
productivity its measured and it's not
measuring the productivity that the
impact that they have on others around
them right if you're a happy customer
service employee your customers are
happy you're you know your business is
better if you you know if you're happy
you make your colleagues happy they add
a little bit of their 12 percent
everything starts to roll from there now
you know I worked at Google for years
and people would think that you know we
we have game rooms and we offer coffees
and sushi because we're nice no no it's
a Wii you know Google was very wise to
to make to create an environment where
people are happy happy people are more
productive
they commit more to what they work on
they you know they report less absent
leaves they don't change jobs as often
they don't complain about other benefits
and perks because they enjoy what
they're doing right it's the wise thing
to do
happiness is not a luxury on and it's
not a luxury in our relationship and
it's not a luxury when we raise our
children and and that's the biggest
biggest biggest issue we have is that we
you know we were talking before we we
came here about the world that we live
in today that is a result of the Great
Depression and World War two of
everything that you live in today that
enormous greed that enormous
competitiveness the individual focus is
just a big trauma that our grandparents
went through and and then decided you
know what I don't want you to ever
suffer like I did and and the insurance
policy I'm going to give you is called
success right let's go out there and
make sure that you're successful that so
that you'll never really suffer right
and and as we try to chase that success
we ignore everything that matters and
you know we ignore the path we ignore
this moment which is a wonderful moment
regardless of if you make a hundred
dollars at the end of the months or a
billion dollars at the end of your life
by the way even when you do get there
you're gonna go like ah just a billion
maybe I should just kill myself for
another five years and make another
billion and I've seen that so often it's
just delusional it's it's just constant
striving for something you don't need to
buy things that you don't want to
impress people that you don't like like
yeah